so right here we have a classic
geometric random variable we're defining
it as the number of independent trials
we need to get a success where the
probability of success for each trial is
lowercase p and we have seen this before
when we introduced ourselves to
geometric random variables now the goal
of this video is to think about well
what is the expected value of a
geometric random variable like this
and i'll tell you the answer in future
videos we will apply this formula but in
this video we're actually going to prove
it to ourselves mathematically but the
expected value of a geometric random
variable is going to be 1 over the
probability of success on any given
trial so now let's prove it to ourselves
so
the expected value
of any random variable is just going to
be the probability weighted outcomes
that you could have so you could say it
is the probability
the probability that our random variable
is equal to one times one plus the
probability that our random variable is
equal to two times two plus and you get
the general idea it goes on and on and
on and a geometric random variable it
can only take on values 1 2 3 4 so forth
and so on it will not take on the value
0 because you cannot have a success if
you have not had a trial yet
but what is this going to be equal to
well this is going to be equal to what's
the probability that we have a success
on our first trial and actually let me
just write it over here
so this is going to be
p
what is this going to be what is the
probability that we don't have a success
on our first trial but we have one on
our second trial well this is going to
be
one minus p that's the first trial where
we don't have a success times a success
on the second trial and actually let me
do a few more terms here so let me erase
this a little bit do a few more terms so
this is going to be the probability that
x equals 2.
sorry the probability that x equals
3
times 3 and we're going to keep going on
and on and on well what's this going to
be
well the probability that x equals 3
is we're going to have to get
two
unsuccessful trials and so the
probability of two unsuccessful trials
is 1 minus p squared
and then one successful trial just like
that so you get the general idea if i
wanted to rewrite this i'm just going to
rewrite it to make it a little bit
simpler
so the expected
at least for the purposes of this proof
so the expected value of x is equal to
i'll write this as 1 p
plus 2 p
times 1 minus p
plus
3 p
times 1 minus p squared and we're going
to go keep going on and on and on
forever like that so how do we figure
out this sum and now i'm going to do a
little bit of mathematical trickery or
gymnastics but it's all valid
and if any of you all have seen the
proof of taking a infinite geometric
series then we're going to do a very
similar technique
what i'm going to do here is i'm going
to think about well what is 1 minus p
times this expected value so let's do
that so if i say
1 minus p
times the expected value of x what is
that going to be equal to
well i would multiply every one of these
terms times 1 minus p so 1p times 1
minus p would be
1
p
times 1 minus p you would get that right
over there what about 2 p times 1 minus
p what would that be equal to well that
would be 2 p
times 1 minus p and now we're going to
multiply it by 1 minus p again so you're
going to get 1 minus p squared and so i
think you see where this is going and
we're just going to keep adding and
adding and adding from there
now we're going to do something really
fun and interesting at least from a
mathematical point of view
if this is equal to that if the
left-hand side is equal to the
right-hand side let's just subtract this
value from both sides so on the
left-hand side i would have the expected
value of x that's that
minus this minus 1 minus p
times the expected
value of x so i'm just subtracting this
from that side but let me do subtract
this from that side well i could
subtract this expression from that but
this is equivalent so i'm just going to
subtract this from that and so what do i
get
well let's see i'm going to have 1 minus
p
and then if i subtract 1 p times 1 minus
p from 2p times 1 minus p well i'm just
going to be left with plus
1
p times
1 minus p
and then if i subtract this from that
i'm going to be left with 1 p times
1
minus p
squared and we're just going to keep
going on and on and on
and so let me simplify this a little bit
if i distribute this negative this could
be plus
and then this would be p minus 1. and
then if we distribute this expected
value of x we get on the left-hand side
the let me scroll up a little bit i
don't want to scrunch it too much
so let's see we have the expected value
of x
and then plus
p times the expected value of x
p times the expected value of x minus
the expected value of x these cancel out
is going to be equal to
p
plus p times 1 minus p
plus p times 1 minus p squared and it's
going to keep going on and on and on
well on the left hand side all i have is
a p times expected value of x if i want
to solve for the expected value of x i
just divide both sides by p so i get and
this is kind of neat through this
mathematical gymnastics i now have i'm
just dividing everything by p both sides
on the left hand side i just have the
expected value of x if i divide all of
these terms by p this first term becomes
1. the second term becomes 1
minus p
this third term if i divide by p becomes
plus
1 minus p
squared so forth and so on now what's
cool about this this is a classic
geometric series
with a common ratio of 1 minus b
and if that term is completely
unfamiliar to you i encourage you and
this is why it's actually called a
geometric one of the reasons arguments
for why it's called a geometric random
variable but i encourage you to review
what a geometric series is on khan
academy if this looks completely
unfamiliar but in other places we proved
using actually a very similar technique
that we did up here that this sum is
going to be equal to 1 over
1 minus our common ratio and our common
ratio is 1
minus p
so what is this going to be equal to and
we are really in the home stretch right
over here this is going to be equal to 1
over
1 minus 1 plus p 1 minus 1 plus p
which is indeed equal to 1 over p so
there you have it we have proven to
ourselves that the expected value of a
geometric random variable using some i
i think cool mathematics is indeed equal
to 1
over p